heys we are back and we're talking to
Lee who's going to tell us a bit about
Skylanders imaginative and I think this
is wonderful and I'm really excited
about it awesome ever since I I mean
I'll get you to talk about it because
you'll say it better than me but ever
since I saw the fact that you guys have
basically shaped this whole thing around
like kids drawings just being like so
excited about this game I'm wanting to
have their own little critters in it
because they love you all so much and
obviously they're drawing their own and
that you're like yeah we're going to
facilitate that it just warms my heart
and it makes me so happy so please just
brief me just tell me a game sure sure
sure so Skylanders imagine aters it's
our sixth Skylanders game when ya mind
blowing yeah and so we have the guys who
created and pioneered this toys the life
John Rhodes virus adventure it's a team
called toys for Bob yep and they're
making basically that power to create
your own Skylander and giving it to kids
yeah very first time and so ever since
we released that first game we've been
getting drawings pictures non-stop ideas
of what kids would want to have you know
their Skylanders be and so what we did
was kind of looked at what was common
about all those drawings is that they
don't want to just make something that
looks like a Skylander they want to make
something that plays like a Skylander
like a Skylander and so using this what
we call creation crystal which is all
fan like to see that there and you put
that on the portal and then at that
point and get to create your own
character from scratch by going to
different categories like body and
choosing all the different parts yeah
you can choose all the different sizes
you can give them a cool added aura or
glow to your character and then from
there you can go and collect gear to put
on your character which yeah just the
stats of your character you can choose
all the different powers that they have
by mixing and matching our elements of
our characters as well as what we call
battle classes which yeah fighting style
so if you want to be a ninja you can be
a ninja yeah want to be a bazooka you
can be a bazooka or a night or 10
different types of fighting styles and
then on top of that you get to create
your own catchphrase
choosing your voice yeah it's crazy I
just want to call attention to the
screen because I feel like this is
really important it's not just like you
guys have made a few options available
it's really there's so much stuff that
you enables there is so much there
they're like head eyes is you can really
and and there is not enough tails dozens
and dozens and dozens hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds action it's in
fantastic yeah one yeah and so you can
see the character we're creating here is
a bow slinger which is our kind of our
archer class yeah and so we've got
pencil ears we've got slightly hair
we've gotta think a robotic Knight lux
oh yeah well you've got sleeve light is
you got it off my favorite way is eight
we have a tail width slider which is the
yes the big big dick tail yeah really
narrow tail camera buff let's make sure
we have comido body I like it it's a
making sure that we have both the
accessibility for a younger audience and
having the game to a lot of heavy
lifting for creativity but then also
allowing there to be the depth for
someone who's as obsessive as me to go
in yeah go into colors and choose every
single items individual color at all so
if you look at the character be like oh
you know he looks great man I wish those
gloves yeah loves were a darker shade of
green you can go in there that's
manually change everything what about
the reception from this like kids
playing at our adults who of playing it
I mean what's it been like I mean even
at the show right now you've taken it
upon ourselves not to make there has not
been the same character twice I'm so
just seeing everyone get their hands on
it seeing everyone create their own
completely awesome character some are
going more you know heroic and
adventurous some are going spooky some
are going kind of silly and goofy and
that's what makes Skylanders so great is
that we have all those different aspects
and they really appealed everybody and
so putting that in the power of
everyone's hands and seeing what kids
and players are coming up with has just
been eye-opening it's been really cool
to see what people do with it and it's
just so awesome so far that's been
testing yeah
what are we talking about like gameplay
wise and other additions that we're
seeing ya so in addition to creating the
characters with the creation crystal in
the imagine aters one of the big things
that we're showing this e3 are our
senses which is another classic
character and so if you think of the the
imaginator this created Skylander in the
crystal as kind of the apprentice these
senses are the masters a lab so they
represent kind of let the peak battle
class abilities and one of the big
things that we're talking about is that
we have brought in Crash Bandicoot yeah
as one of these senses let's talk about
it yes crash sensei once we teach me
your ways he is a brawler mm-hmm because
he uses those hand to hand you know
spinning attacks and so yeah what we've
done is we've actually looked at kind of
the history of crash we looked at all
the things that made crash special and
give my boo pible knows I believe it's
very mobile to be very visual a
technical train and so in addition to
having a bootable knows he has just a
really great play style that pays a lot
of homage to kind of his history because
the 20th year of crash which is crazy
and so in addition to having him in
imagine aters which we wanted to do to
you know kind of introduce him to a
whole new line of gamers next year we're
going to be creating remasters of the
first three crash games yeah just crazy
but in imagine aters we wanted to make
sure that people got that taste got in
there yeah that's how he played and so
see he's got this really cool spin
attack which you know is indicative of
his original attacks and very first
games he's got the ability to do this
really cool kick and flip attack but
then he can also throw out crates which
are from the very first game is what's
needed that how you can then mix your
own attacks and to kind of those
different power so by tossing out the
crates you can then do your spin attack
to create a tornado to hurl those into
enemies yeah and so a lot of really fun
things there and then we've even pushed
it further by making him the only
Skylander with multiple lives okay that
was defeated he does one of his original
and
nations for when he got defeated in the
original game so have a halo and some
little wings fly off screen before
popping back up from the ground amazing
through an our IP tombstone or he has a
wampa fruit launcher and the jet-pack
that yet so really just going in and
paying a lot of attention to the history
of the character has been a lot of fun
what about crash makes him to use such a
good fit for the Skylanders universe
well honestly it's the fact that he's
got so much history and so last year we
were able to have a really cool
partnership with Nintendo and created
Donkey Kong and Bowser characters
scaling superchargers and this year
going into crash I mean our team is
really really well versed in the history
of video games where gamers we love
games and so being able to look at what
made him so special and layering that
into his upgrade chains and allowing him
to play in this world is just phenomenal
for us awesome really cool I can also
imagine it must be pretty exciting given
you know you do have this huge audience
of quite young people young children you
probably haven't been exposed to crash
the same a little bit then you've got
that parents who are playing with them
who have like a crush like growing up or
a teenager's a little but it must be
really nice yeah to like bring that
together I mean honestly that's that is
totally true i mean it's the same thing
with spyro with having spire on
skylanders and so having the history but
then also reintroducing that to new
gamers it's just been really cool and so
since our game is really kind of a fun
family game for everyone not just those
young gamers it's been great to see kind
of couch co-op evolved and we can have
it where you can play as an imaginator
created character with crash bandicoot
and so you can have you know the
original marsupial there in the game as
well as a brand new created characters
playing together and so it's a really
fun way to see kind of the history all
in one package it's really neat yeah it
just it seems so wonderful to me it's
like when I was a kid I love to like
watching my dad play games like okay
they would usually like planescape
torment but it's like I got so much out
of having that spectator experience and
to have
not only just this game but this genre
that is really enabling like family play
and getting kids into games at a young
age it just must be such a fantastic
thing it is I mean Laura it's nuts i
mean i've been on the the franchise
since Giants and so it's been a long
time and it's been great just to see how
more players come in and players grow up
with it or adult find it and kinda have
fun with their kids and it's just been a
really great experience just to see that
and so I mean for this year it's kind of
the really a big culmination of what
we've done in the past years and so
giving kids and parents and anyone who
wants to play that power to create just
been completely mind-boggling yeah so
putting that in the hands of the players
and getting to see how that changes this
whole conversation of what kind of the
toys the life game can be is something
that we are completely excited yeah yeah
quite conscious of when when you're
developing or when you're working on you
know the sequel or the next version of
Skylanders you want to do do you have to
be very conscious of younger players
that may not be so quick to learn
mechanics is that quite difficult in the
development person it is I mean one of
the things that we do is really focus on
this game as being someone's first game
as well as being enjoyable for someone
who's well-versed in drums and so yeah
it's it's hard to imagine but kind of
like that jump from say like six to
twelve yeah it's a small period of time
but the amount of hey you know depth of
learning that happens for gamers at that
point yeah it's crazy and so yeah we do
spend a lot of time making sure that
we're very communicative we're very of
teaching things we're not also taking
for granted things that I may know as a
gamer and so that's one of the things
that we make sure to do is go through
and make sure that it is a fun and great
experience for everyone but then has
that depth and so that's kind of our
design mentality for everything and so I
was mentioning that with this or the
creation you can go in and we've got
features to allow the game to do a lot
of that creation for you you can
randomize it and so someone who's really
young can go in get it immediately and
play and then someone who really wants
to spend that time for the depth of the
experience we don't forget about them
too because we're were those people Alan
so going in adding univ stats to the
gear so that you can be kind of the the
really kind of
core character creator is going to
create a character focus only on speed
yeah you can do that we do that with the
gameplay as well and so we've got in our
multiple difficulty levels I mean our
nightmare mode is one of the hardest the
type seeking really yeah people should
know yeah yeah now you're a mere road is
awesome and so in this game I mean it's
gonna be kind of that fun really
authentic RPG experience of building
your character getting the best gear
hopping into the hardest mode yeah and
go through and so it's really a game
that kind of grows with your experience
yeah so it's a ton of fun had no idea
Skylanders had a nightmare we have a
nightmare mode yes you heard him first
Skylanders the dark souls of hot
commodities um yeah I mean this is just
I I just think it's really exciting I
think you guys are doing really cool
stuff I mean how do you feel about the
toys to life genre I mean do you think
it's something that is going to become
obviously it's pretty much emerged over
the last six years or so do you think
it's gonna be a staple I mean I hope so
of yeah hey did you watch I mean as you
but no I mean for us part of the reason
that we you know think it's so special
is because of how we tackle it yeah you
know I mean when we when we came up with
a Skylanders concept bringing a toy to
life wasn't commonplace yeah and now we
have kids have grown up with it and you
kind of have to take at face value that
yeah that's now a default level of
expectation yeah and so it's not
something where we just rest on our
laurels making the same game yeah
continually coming up with a brand new
way to play yeah a new innovation and
something new and fresh to keep it
magical and really that's for us the
spirit of this entire kind of category
or genre yes almost the feeling of its
being magical or something unbelievable
now you know bring to the player how
will last quite quickly do you feel like
Disney folding infinity impacts on the
genre at all are on how you guys are
doing your thing with Scotland I mean
honestly no just because we spend so
much time making these games I mean
we've been already been working on this
for years we're coming out not over
and game development son yeah really a
game development is not like this crazy
a quick pivoting thing and so for us
it's always been heads down focus on
innovation focus on making sure that we
are bringing players something special
and unique yeah and so really that's
what defines our franchise and defines
us is you know kind of a you know series
and so that's always been our focus yeah
when you do make sequels like this one
or the ones you've made before it does
it a lot of the ideas for what you want
to do with them come internally or do
you just hear a lot about what people
want next in the game and you're like
okay we'll make that happen I mean it's
a bit of both yeah I mean so when we see
kids sending in their own pictures one
way to interpret that is oh I literally
want that as a toy in the game yep
versus say I want the ability to create
that as they told you in the game so
making sure that we're looking and
figuring out not just what we as gamers
would like to see but also trying to
figure out what the gamer would like to
see but also presenting it in a new and
unique way and so kind of pushing the
boundaries and making it feel magical
putting our spin on it making it
something that can only exist as a
Skylanders game that's kind of our
objective there yeah that's fantastic so
do you remind us when can we get our
hands on this yeah so game comes out
October sixteenth mm-hmm and so it's
going to be out on the ps3 the ps4 the
xbox one the xbox 360 and the wii u
fantastic and we're totally excited
about it and then we were really excited
because this morning we actually
announced that Netflix is going to be
distributing a Skylanders Academy TV
show hey is so cool oh my god awesome
yes it'll be out this fall and we've got
to 13 episodes seasons lined up Wow
we're actually producing it we have a an
Activision film in studio department and
it's gonna be awesome that's awesome
yeah that sounds really epic thank you
so much for talking to us about the game
I think it just sounds fantastic I
literally cannot say that enough uh yeah
have a great rest assure and we will be
back shortly but in the meantime enjoy
whatever's playing in the meantime
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads bites